European
thank you very much
magnifico retore for your kind words
president matarella it's such an honor
and a pleasure to be with you in your
hometown
minister banini representatives of the
Sicilian institutions
dear professors
carry student
it is such a pleasure to be with you in
the beautiful city of Palermo
one of the capitals of the Mediterranean
one of the cradles of European culture
and what an honor to celebrate with you
217 years of history for the University
of Palermo
we are meeting on a very special day for
Europe
one year ago
tomorrow
Russia launched its brutal invasion of
Ukraine
and seen from Sicily this may look like
a far away conflict
it is not
the young people of Ukraine
share exact the same desires as all
young Europeans like you
they want to be independent
they want to be masters of their own
future
they want to live in a democratic
country that gives freedom
freedom of speech
freedom of thought
freedom of movement
and this is why young Ukrainian wrapped
themselves
in a European flag and took to the
streets
in 2014
and the answer came immediately
in reaction
Putin invaded their country for the
first time
then
eight years later
on February 24th
in 2022
Putin invaded Ukraine again
and he's very clear in his message
Putin denies Ukraine the right to exist
and in attacking Ukraine one year ago
by sending tanks over the Border an
international recognized border
he also attacked the principles of
sovereignty
and territorial integrity
he attacked the principles of democracy
freedom
Independence
the rule of law
not the right of Might
for it is the attractiveness of our
liberal democracies that the autocrats
fear our economic success
our civil liberties
and the freedom of speech and ideas
and that is why the brave Ukrainian
people
are not only defending their own country
but they are also fighting for our
values that is why we will stand by
Ukraine for as long as it takes
ladies and gentlemen dear friends
it is open in the darkest hours that we
find our Inner Strength
and this is what's happening in our
European Union
the last three years have probably been
the most testing ever for Europe
first with the pandemic
and its economic Fallout we tend to
forget
then with this atrocious War
and the spike in the cost of living
but these crises have taught us
something important
we have learned that our Destinies as
Europeans
are tied together
for example during the pandemic when we
procured vaccines we made sure
that they reached all of Europe at the
same time for the same price whether
it's a big member states or small member
state
where there is a rich member state or
not so rich member state
when we built our recovery plan Next
Generation EU do you call it piano
we focused first and foremost on the
regions and sectors in greatest need of
our support
and when Russia turned off the gas step
making our energy builds much more
expensive skyrocketing prices
we responded with European solidarity
sharing us protecting the most
vulnerable families and businesses
this is the kind of Europe I believe in
a union that always stands by its people
and it is this idea of Europe that
brings me to Sicily today
Sicily
has always been the center of the
Mediterranean
a place where different cultures meet
and meddle together
this is the home of Grant Greek temples
and shiny Byzantine mosaics
it's a land shaped by Normans and Arabs
it's the home of Brilliant Minds like
Luigi pirandello
and Luca parmitano
and this unique Sicilian Heritage has
made Palermo a European capital of
culture of Art
of science listening to uretore
and today I finally understand the words
of my compatriot ghouta who wrote
once you see Palermo you will never
forget it
[Applause]
but I also know that in your daily life
you feel sometimes far away from the
heart of Europe
today I'm here to tell you that Sicily
is at the center of Europe
Sicily is in the core
of the European project
and even more
the quote I gave you from Gutta goes on
to say
Sicily holds the key to all things
end of quote
and these words are still true today
because this beautiful island is
absolutely Central to addressing some of
the greatest issues of our times
first
for the transition to clean energy
second for migration
and third for building an economy that
works for Europe's Next Generation
so let me start with the transition to
clean energy
I know how much your generation cares
about climate and you are so right
no task is more vital than stopping
global warming
so I am delighted to see that today
you're opening your Academic Year with a
focus
on sustainability
three years ago
when I took this mandate as president of
the European commission My First Act was
to launch the European green deal
and since then the urgency of the clean
transition has only grown stronger
when Putin started preparing the
invasion of Ukraine he blacked melas
with our dependency on Russian fossil
fuels and yes there was a strong
overdependency on Russian coal on
Russian oil and on Russian gas
the impact
of him tightening the grip on energy
was felt all across Europe including of
course Sicily
but we have managed to break free from
our dependency and from his blackmail
we have together replaced Russian gas
with reliable supplies for example from
our friends in the United States
or Norway or Algeria
we have massively invested in renewable
clean energy
Italy has cut its Imports of Russian gas
by two-thirds in record time
actually in Europe we reduced the import
of Russian gas by 80 in eight months
and as a result of this effort and of
this unity in the European Union prices
for gas today
are lower than before the Russian war
started
but
our work doesn't end here
this is now the moment
to speed up rapidly the transition to
Homegrown clean Renewables because
Renewables are not only good for the
climate yes they are good for the
climate
but as they are homegrown they create
good jobs here
they are also good for our security and
for our independence
and Sicily
can become a European clean energy
Powerhouse
not only do you have
an abundance of sun and wind of course
on this island
and it's all about resources
but you also have a strong clean tech
Industrial basis
earlier this month
construction Works have begun right here
in Sicily
for the largest solar gigafactory in
Europe
it will build a new generation of solar
panels
Next Generation EU our European recovery
plan is contributing to its funding
because we know that clean energy is the
future
and this future
is made here in Sicily it's in your
hands and Europe needs you
Sicily is Central
to our energy transition also for
another region reason
right in front of your Shores lies
another clean energy Powerhouse and that
is Africa
Africa's potential is immense for solar
for wind power and for green hydrogen
too
so Europe must reach out to the Southern
Shores
and Sicily is the natural bridge builder
since the beginning of the Russian war
Italy has done an impressive job with
African Partners to diversify its energy
Supply
and our Union is creating new
connections with Africa through our
global gateway investment plan
for instance we are now financing a new
undersea electric electricity cable
between Sicily and Tunisia
so time has come for a new European
pivot to the Mediterranean
the second issue I'd like to address is
migration
Sicily today is both
a land of immigration
and of immigration
on the one hand
you have welcomed Through The Years
countless people who have landed on your
Shores
on the other hand so many young people
like you
have chosen to leave and follow their
dreams elsewhere
because this is what migration is all
about
it's about searching for opportunities
it's about dreams
and yet
to open
for people who fall into the dirty hands
of Smugglers and traffickers
the dreams turn into a nightmare
and this is not how things should be
think for example about the humanitarian
corridors that have been created right
here in Sicily by churches and local
communities
it's a safe alternative for those who
flee from work
and this model can be supported by the
European Union
there is a basic principle that should
drive our action and that is
that migration can be managed
we need to have safe Pathways to reach
Europe for those who have a right to
protection
we have to fight the Smugglers and the
traffickers and stop this tragic loss of
life
we need to speak with our partner
countries work with them
on the return of those who do not have
the right to stay
and we must cooperate at the European
level
Europe must show solidarity to all
member states and local communities
and all member states should act
together
for a challenge we all share
this is essentially the spirit of the
new pact for migration and Asylum which
we have proposed
and earlier this month the meeting of
European leaders has recognized a very
simple fact but it took 10 years to
acknowledge it
migration
is a European challenge
and it needs a European answer
we must all do our part and we all need
each other's support
so we now have a plan
which we need to take forward together
a European solution is possible and I
will work as hard as possible to reach
this goal
a European system
that works for Sicily
and for all of Europe
my third and final Point has to do with
you
the young people in the audience
I believe my generation's greatest
responsibility
is to leave Europe a better place for
the Next Generation
you would dear Rector
have just mentioned the beautiful quote
by hansionas
on the imperative of responsibility
for future Generations
and this is first and foremost about
climate action
but it is also about building an economy
that works for young people
because it is not always the case today
one young person in three
does not work or study
less than one woman in three
has a job
so it is clear that things must change
and this is why we called our recovery
plan Next Generation EU
because it is all about making Europe
fit for the Next Generation
it is all about opportunity and new
sustainable jobs throughout our Union
Italy is the largest beneficiary of this
huge investment program 200 billion
euros
the bank of Italy says the plan will
create 375
000 new jobs in our country in your
country
and at least 40 percent of Italy's PNR
plan is coming to Southern Italy
with these Investments and reforms
Sicily can become a land for young
people
this region is home of so much talent I
listen to you
Sicily performs way above the European
average
for the quality of your scientific
Publications
even if research and development
Investments here are way below the
average so it's time to invest in you
for instance we are now financing 240
new posts for researchers and PhD
students right here at the University of
Palermo
and there is one of your projects I
really care about being a medical doctor
by training
you're putting a very strong focus on
Health Care
creating the first first center in Italy
on digital Health prevention so this is
great news not only for young and
aspiring doctors but for all people in
Sicily
Next Generation EU is also investing in
a new chips factory
close to Catania
it will be the first of its kind in
Europe the first
Shield it will produce chips that we
currently import from Southeast Asia
and it will create 700 high-skilled jobs
right here
these are the good jobs you are studying
for you are working so hard for
but of course
this job offer also has to be
complemented
by a broad supply of good child care and
good schools
because this is a precondition for young
families
young mothers
and Young Fathers have to be able to
reconcile work and family
because we should be so proud of young
couples
that take the responsibility
and decide to raise children and to have
a career
to earn their own income we should not
give them hurdles and criticism but we
should help them and we should proudly
proud of them this is the kind of
opportunity that you deserve
and all of this
is at the heart of Next Generation EU
we can make Europe the place of your
dreams
because you are the ones
who will carry on the torch of
responsibility
and I'm confident that you will rise to
the challenge
president matarella there is a quote
from your brother
that really strikes me
he believed that Italy and Europe have a
responsibility
to help southern Italy transform itself
but he also said and I quote
progress cannot be imposed from above
it needs to be driven
by our hidden energy and enthusiasm end
of quote and this is what makes me
confident
you the young people of Sicily your
passion your ideas Your Enthusiasm
your talent your knowledge you are the
hidden energy of this island and its
inner beauty you make it
so best luck for the Academic Year Viva
La Sicilia Viva La Europa
thank you
pronunci